non je pense que c'est plus un
laboratoire
c'est le cimetière des éléphants a
expliqué noah mais je vais vous
expliquer je pense que le rôle premier
d'un parlementaire c'est de siéger
essaie notamment de voter le budget la
droite a fait un choix ça voulait pas
digérer ça mais je n'ai pas digéré
quand on pense au nombre de gens à
droite comme à gauche qui veulent
supprimer le sénat
quand la droite supprime le budget au
sénat que reste-t-il et donc je crois
vraiment que par rapport à ce que disait
le président gérard larcher pour lequel
j'ai le plus le plus grand respect c'est
un c'est un bon président du sénat y a
pas de sujet mais il disait nous voulons
construire le budget de l'alternance est
là pour des raisons politiques et
politiciennes ne seront pas amenés à
voter le budget à aborder le budget même
pas comme il l'avait fait en 2012 et
2013 au moins la première partie rien
rien du tout la droite refuse le débat
car elle sait je la ferme ce soir elle
sait que les propositions dont nous
venons de parler s'était mis là sur la
table aujourd'hui leur servirait pas
pour l'élection présidentielle ils sont
capables de sacrifices vous l'avez nord
aujourd'hui on disait comme les enfants
disent je peux pas venir j'ai piscine
aujourd'hui ce que dit la la droite
sénatoriale c'est moi je peux pas venir
j'ai primaire donc voilà bien que
politique vous dites en quelque sorte
que la primaire s'est invitée au sénat
elle est victime un petit peu de cette
primaire la primaire s'est invitée au
sénat et le sénat est victime de la
primaire et de fait la conséquence c'est
qu'il n'y aura pas de budget et je pense
que ce n'est pas bien du tout pour le
sénat c'est une et pour les sénateurs
c'est une faute politique qu'il croit
faute grave alors bien entendu par
rapport à tout ce que l'on voit là
aujourd'hui il faut relativiser mais je
pense que ça comme le pendant ce
populisme jambes dans ce populisme dans
tout ce qu'ils montrent du doigt les
parlementaires tous ceux qui montrent du
doigt le sénat senate sert à rien ça
coûte cher il ya une deuxième chambre ne
pas siéger pour voter le budget parce
qu'on va siéger lors des débats des
discussions pour occuper la galerie pour
que public sénat puisse tourner c'est
l'après midi sans son émission 360 etc
c'est pour ça qu'ils font ça je suppose
c'est pas à la hauteur de l'événement
vraiment nous aurions aimé nous aurions
aimé nous qu'en 2011 rappelez vous
lorsque nous avons pris nous avons été
majoritaires au sénat le plf 2012 nous
avons fait le plf de l'alternance nous
et aujourd'hui ils prennent des
prétextes fallacieux d un article 40 ce
n'est pas possible c'est faux et kaino
disculpe budget est insincère et
électoralistes rendez le sincère mais
baisser le nombre de fonctionnaires le
budget des fonctionnaires augmenter la
augmenter la tva c'est fort c'est fort
possible passé aux 39 heures mais ils ne
veulent pas le faire parce qu'ils savent
très bien qu'aujourd'hui ils sont dans
leurs primaires et il s'adresse à la
droite et la droite je pense peut se
retrouver sur ce programme de cassure
sociale savait et alain juppé en 1995
lorsqu'il était premier ministre parce
qu'il faut se rappeler était premier
ministre en 1995 il ya 22 ans 21 ans il
voulait se battre contre la fracture
sociale là il veut assumer la cassure
sociale et françois fillon qui a
toujours voulu dire du sang et des
larmes faut dire la vérité aux français
j'ai un pays en faillite mais là
aujourd'hui ne dis pas que les comptes
sont redressés et françois fillon dit on
va leur en faire baver et notamment aux
plus vulnérables et bien ce tournant
demandé ce soir de tout est sur la table
surtout sur la table les nounous se
déprécier leur budget nous sommes prêts
et nous sommes prêts il travaillait à
participer nous en avons parlé en
commission des finances allez-y cet
après midi c'était absolument ahurissant
ce qui s'est passé nous étions
commission des finances pour aborder le
budget des collectivités territoriales
avec deux amendements qui était présenté
par les rapporteurs de la commission
alors que on ne va pas en débattre
ça n'a aucun sens mais aucun sens alors
parce que nous sommes des humains de
lorsque nous sommes des du responsable
nous allons commission nous disons que
nous ne partageons pas leur leur avis
d'ailleurs la présidente de la
commission des finances l'a dit tout à
l'heure il ya beaucoup de budget qui ont
été votées en commission des finances
mais chaque fois que la droite s'étale
tout sénatoriales vote quand un budget
elle vote pas contre parce que ce budget
est trop important il dépense trop elle
votre compte parce qu'elle jamais assez
jamais assez ce n'est pas ce différend
quelle image cela revoir le sénat et est
ce que vous estimez qu'il ya une part de
responsabilité de la part du président
du sénat ah oui bien sûr il ya une part
de responsabilité président du fida moi
je pense que le président du sénat
aurait dû imposer imposé que le ce débat
se tienne et ce budget s'inscrit à moins
qu'ils le fassent mais peut-être je vous
dis ils étaient trop occupés par leur
primaire peut-être qu'ils ont préfet
prioriser la primaire au budget je crois
que c'est regrettable un parlementaire
qui n'a pas accès au budget qui ne peut
pas en débattre voter les recettes de
l'état votée les dépenses ne fait pas
son boulot n'est vous dites donc ses
responsabilités aussi également du
président du sénat